it's okay you know but i'm trying to win
the super bowl and we taking the game at
a time i'm not worried about mvp you
know if you come and come i'll be
satisfied but i'm trying to win a super
bowl that's a team award and that's what
i want
lamar jackson after the game making it
clear he is not interested in winning
the mvp although he'll take it if he
gets it the goal is to get to the super
bowl and win it always better to be the
super bowl mvp than the regular season
mvp and last year's regular season mvp
patrick mahomes this year the front
runner is lamar jackson and chris
something that i considered earlier
today and we've talked about it a little
bit and we talked about it off air and
you really don't want to give me an
answer who would you rather have right
now patrick mahomes or lamar jackson
well i mean there's no easy answer here
i mean these are guys that are both like
transcendent players they're you know
once
you know in a generation type players
really maybe lamar jackson and his
talents or it might be even more
rare than patrick mahomes and that's
saying something because i mean we saw
again let's not forget
patrick mahomes did things last year
that we have never seen before in the
history of the nfl it was that special
i think if you really you know you know
put a gun to my head i'd probably still
go with patrick mahomes i would that's
not easy for me to say it's very close
i think the uh the world of lamar
jackson and his talents you know i was a
huge fan of his coming out in the draft
and everything like that uh but mahomes
you know i do think his style of play
maybe lasts the test of time a little
bit more also i'll say this mike it's
hard for me to comprehend the offense of
lamar jackson hey i'm i'm pocket
quarterback guy right you know so i i'm
still getting my head wrapped around
this offense before my i'm more used to
what i see with patrick mahomes than i
do lamar jackson so i think that kind of
plays a fact to where like if i was an
offensive coordinator in the nfl i don't
know if i could build the lamar jackson
offense i think i could build the
patrick mahomes offense uh so i think
that's where i kind of lean that way or
why i lean that way a little bit
i think the other reality too is lamar
jackson is going to burn more brightly
but burn out before that's what i mean
right yeah mahomes is gonna do what he's
doing for the next 15 years right is
lamar jackson going to be doing what
he's doing for the next 15 years i think
lamar jackson is going to be a more
limited life cycle but but maybe better
at times
including right now during that process
i mean we worry about lamar jackson
getting injured who got injured this
year it was mahomes yeah right no you're
right i mean but and the other thing is
yeah will lamar jackson be able to
continue to have these highlight 45-yard
runs you know
nine and ten years from now probably not
but you know what we know is he's going
to be a much better packet passer and
quarterback that way too he is proving
to us that he wants to be a pocket
quarterback like you said earlier in the
show he's not looking to force these
plays and these runs and these highlight
you know type real uh you know scrambles
and all of that he is in the pocket
going through reeds and if there's a
hole or a window hey he he unleashes the
kraken and throws a rifle in there but
if it's not there then he tucks so he is
a throw first quarterback when it comes
to the drop back pass game and i think
that will help his overall life cycle of
his career as well
here's the other thing too last year
when mahomes was doing what he was doing
i said there's going to be a generation
of kids who try to do all those same
things and there will be
guys in the future 15 20 years from now
if not sooner in the nfl who play like
mahomes yeah i don't know we're going to
see a guy play like lamar jackson
the next you know as like it's a once in
20-year type of a talent you either have
that ability or you don't for for a lot
of the stuff my homes does and the the
arm strength is incredible right but i
feel like it there's a better chance of
there being another mahomes yeah before
there's going to be another lamar i
agree hey like my little boy philip sims
hey he's got no chance of ever being
lamar jackson you know if he hey hey hey
buddy you're a sims you ain't gonna be
able to run like that sorry now you know
yes for you know the throwing wise i'm
not saying he could be patrick mahomes
but you're right it's easier for a kid
to think i could be that over lamar
jackson you gotta run 4-3 to be lamar
jackson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports